good afternoon everyone
I'm really happy we added this session
last minute looks like everyone's happy
about that as well I hope you're all
excited to learn about async and
awaiting JavaScript
I'm joking
took a few seconds I hope no one left
on the way in now we're going to be
talking about async and await and using
that in c-sharp and Dot net of course
and we're going to focus on efficiency
and talking about how to efficiently use
async and await the task para Library
what this means to our applications how
to break applications and why that might
occur and how to fix it
so this is going to be an interesting
session hopefully all of you are going
to go out of this session with a little
bit of a headache but don't worry I've
got some paddle if you need that
joking my name is Philip I did a session
earlier today on all the things in
c-sharp I quickly showed some things
that are new to.net in terms of async
and await but now we're going to focus
on really getting into exactly what the
task parallel libraries how to use that
and if you have any questions afterwards
because we're going to cover quite a lot
of things in just one hour feel free to
send me an email I I happily talk to
developers about async and await
c-sharp.net and all of that so do email
me if you have any questions
so the first thing that we want to
answer is why would we even bother in
producing asynchronous principles
parallelism and doing things on another
thread than the UI thread
quite the obvious reason is to avoid
unreliable applications in this case
here I have a application running on
Android and it's not the fact that we're
going to solve Android that's a
different problem this here is showing
me that I'm doing way too much work on
the UI thread the operating system is
telling me that you should probably
offload some work to somewhere else
so we're going to solve this with by
introducing the task parallel Library
this is a xamarinore.net Maui
application doesn't really matter all
that we're going to talk about here
today is applicable in any.net
application it's a little bit different
if you're doing asp.net asp.net core
c-sharp for console applications WPF
winforms but we're going to try and
cover some of that as well
so we want to improve the user
experience and we want to efficiently
consume apis and all the data available
to us
so what it really boils down to is that
sometimes we have really powerful
machines this here is a screenshot of my
task manager of my desktop at home
sometimes you run on applications or
systems that are not as powerful so it's
quite nice that.net will take care of
optimizing some of the things for us to
make use of the available resources
efficiently I have CPU I have memory
Network and all of this that I want to
use in my application and it's quite
nice that we can do this with the the
built-in types as long as we know
exactly how to use it efficiently
it really boils down to two things it's
CPU and IO
one of the things that I often talk
about is that we have CPU bound offer
operations that are are you you normally
want to divide a problem into smaller
pieces you want to parallelize a problem
that is very much CPU bound you want to
solve something as quickly as possible
and then you have i o bound operations
which you also want to be happening in
parallel or just somewhere else rather
than blocking the application but you
also want to be able to get a
notification without this done
traditionally you were able to do this
using events so you could use an event
based asynchronous pattern but that's
not very nice instead they're building
things into the language to make it
easier to consume asynchronous apis and
this is of course what we're going to be
looking at
so ideally we're going to go from a
blocking application to non-blocking
code
this means avoid heavy lifting on the UI
or main thread off the application
in terms of asp.net if there's an
asp.net developers in here you're
probably wondering how this is going to
benefit you
there's no UI thread per se but you can
still let the server consume that thread
to process more requests if you block a
thread in asp.net that thread will not
be able to go ahead and handle some
other requests
so we want to avoid that this means that
if we do consume asynchronous apis for
example storing something in a database
using the HTTP client reading something
from a disk you don't want to block that
operation I quite often see developers
do dot result on any tasks
sometimes that's okay as long as you can
guarantee that the task has completed
which can be a little bit tricky to know
now in terms of the the Android
application to make this a little bit
better go from blocking to non-blocking
ideally I don't just want to block the
UI in a different way but at least in
this term I tell the user that something
is going on
you're less likely to kill the
application in this in this case here a
little bit of a better user experience
so how do we do this we introduce a
thing called a task the task was
introduced to simplify concurrent and
asynchronous code it means that we can
do two things which normally are
fundamentally different asynchronous
programming is not the same as parallel
programming parallel programming is
about taking a large problem dividing
that into maybe evening if even chunks
and solving that problem as quickly as
possible whereas a synchronous
programming is about also doing
something in parallel but you expect to
get a result it will tell you when it
has some data available for you to
process
now the task will do that for us and in
fact using task.run it will do quite a
lot of things so what it will do it it
will tell our
dot net runtime that I have some work
that I want to distribute somewhere else
go ahead and put this somewhere else in
my in my runtime and just run it on a
different thread don't block my current
UI thread
now the problem is of course if there
are no threads available this is going
to be put on a queue and the.net runtime
will take care of all of this for you so
you don't have to care too much about
where this is executing or what's going
on behind the scenes it helps to
understand exactly what's Happening Here
but it's not a requirement
but of course we're going to dig into
exactly what's going to happen so
what happens is that it's going to find
a thread now it doesn't necessarily have
to be a threat in terms of now you now
you when you normally start a new thread
or when you have an operating system
thread it will use a managed thread
these threads can be reused that also
means that it might reuse some data
available on that thread to speed things
up it won't clear data across the
different managed threads that means
that you can leak data across your
synchronous operations which can be fine
but you shouldn't rely on static data
you might have noticed this if you've
ever done asp.net older versions where
you can no longer use the HTTP context
which is a static property if you swap
between different asynchronous contexts
so so the solution to this is to try to
avoid static data
because it's unreliable in this case
here
what it also allows me to do when I do
task.ron this will return an instance of
a task that I can subscribe to to tell
me if the work is completed or not
which is great I could say run some work
it doesn't really matter how long that
takes just let me know when that is
completed
now doing task.run on a WPF application
or Windows forms application works
really well you won't run into many
issues with that but when you do this on
for example a mobile the operating
system might say hey you're running way
too much in the background without the
user giving consent to this so they
might terminate the the application or
the thread or you'll run into some
really odd issues
and in the case of asp.net if we do
task.run that will consume a thread on
the thread pool which could have been
used to process another request
so effectively if we do task.run you're
going to half the amount of requests
that your application can handle
which could be a little bit problematic
so with that being said you should never
do task.run in asp.net yourself but
rather consume apis that rely on the
operating systems implementation of the
asynchronous principles
for example I can ask the file system to
give me all the contents of a file and
the operating system handles all of that
interaction for me
and I'm no longer blocking my
application from from processing more
requests
first there are two different versions
of the task either we have some work
that just works or just does something
somewhere else and I still want to be
able to know when that is done or the
second example here is indicating that I
have some operation that's running on a
different thread that will yield some
data both of them will allow me to
subscribe to when they are completed to
know if they are done or not
so let's jump into Visual Studio
and have a little bit of a look at an
application I normally do this in WPF
because it's easy for everyone to see
exactly what's happening
so this is a very simple application I
only have a button that I can click
which runs a method when I do this the
application is going to freeze up and
it's hopefully not going to work because
this is doing something on the UI which
it should not
after two seconds it relieves my my it's
not no longer locking my UI thread and I
can get the result populated in the UI
what I normally see people do in this
case here and sometimes it works but
they simply wrap this method called in a
task.run
what I'm doing now is I'm passing this
delegate or I'm passing My Method into a
task to run to tell it to run this
method on a separate thread
it will go ahead and try to schedule
this work somewhere else
which will of course improve the
experience of the application I can move
everything around and the application is
no longer freezing but I've introduced a
bug
this is the first problem with
introducing a task that you try to wrap
things and just think that it will
magically work better and while the user
experience was in one way better the
application is is no longer performing
as it did before
so the problem here if I run this with a
debugger
it's going to tell me that you are
trying to update the UI from a thread
that does not own that thread
which you're not allowed to do
so to fix this we're going to revert the
code back to just call this method
because this here wasn't really where
the problem was
the problem is inside this
implementation
and I'm doing thread.sleep here
I know some developers use thread.sleep
to solve race conditions it's never a
good idea
this here is to illustrate that I'm
running some heavy computation
could have been something else
now what we could do is that I can
instead say that okay so how about we
just wrap this portion of the code
inside a task.run
which now means that I've offloaded this
work to somewhere else
and of course if I do this it's
immediately going to update the UI but
that's not really what I want what I
want is to say that you can upgrade the
UI once you enter the method I'm going
to start off in a synchronous operation
and then after that is completed I might
want to update the UI this is where we
introduce a concept called a
continuation
task at run returns a task so I could
say run task for example
could probably give it a better name but
you know naming things is really hard
so now I want to say that all of this
code should be only executed once I can
continue from this task I'm then going
to say that all right so once run task
completes I'm going to continue with
some code
this here takes an action of a task
which means that it passes the task that
just completed into its Anonymous method
I could say that I don't care about the
task and then introduce an anonymous
method
and we're going to try to move this code
into this block here
so now what I've done is to say that
after this heavy work is done I'm going
to continue with some other work and
when we run this
it's only going to say hello NDC and
again I'm going to get an exception and
why is that
because the continuation will execute on
a different thread it will try to
schedule this work ideally it will run
inline where this code executed so that
it doesn't have to perform any context
switches because in heavy applications
or or applications with a heavy load
switching with between threads can be
quite time consuming as well as an
expensive operation so it would be
clever if it could just execute this
portion of the code right after it
performed this this tasks operation
but that also means that
I cannot update the UI but it didn't
tell me anything just like before the
application didn't crash I didn't get an
exception that is because when you have
a task that gets an exception inside of
it it's going to capture that it's going
to wrap the exception inside the task so
how would we get this we could ask
and this is where the the older task
parallel Library I shouldn't say older
because I use this a lot still even
though we have the async and Away
keywords
but continue with also returns a task
so I could say that okay I want to know
why this failed so I could say VAR
continue
task
or continuation is probably better
if I can spell that continue
Haitian
whatever
you get the idea right
see so that word here we go so when C
completes I'm going to continue with
something else I'm going to pass the
task that just completed the
continuation task CT for example and now
I can ask if this is faulted or not
so I could now say that if c t dot is
faulted
I could then go ahead and do something
maybe log something maybe check the
exception because there's also a an
exception property here
so I could get the exception of the task
that I'm continuing from
all right so that would be great if I
can do that I could do some logging here
but what if
I'm going to try to log but my log
storage doesn't respond and there's an
exception this continuation then throws
an exception
we'll have to continue and ask for that
as well
get the idea right this is going to get
messy so we're not going to do this
if that fails you can continue as well
so async in a way it will solve this and
make it a little bit better and fluent
for us but we're going to leave this
here so we can see how this is going to
be better what to take from this is that
the continuation also executes somewhere
else it's going to wrap this in a task
so that you can then ask if this
completed or not the the base problem
here is that I'm trying to update the UI
and I can fix this quite easily to say
that I want to capture the UI thread or
the context that owns the UI thread
there's an object in different types of
UI applications such as Maui xamarine
avalonian WPF winforms and whatnot in
winforms this synchronization context is
called the dispatcher the dispatcher is
a let's call it a way for me to
communicate with the UI I can now say
that I want to post some work or invoke
the UI rather I'm going to schedule some
work to run on my UI
and what I'm doing now is that I'm
saying I'm going to run some code
somewhere else on a different thread I
am then going to talk to the UI to
schedule some work and hopefully after
two seconds this application is now
working as intended I can move the
window around and after two seconds it's
going to update the UI yay
however
if you check this into my git repository
you're going to fail the code review
because this doesn't look very nice it's
not very maintainable even though I've
fixed some of my performance issues
maintaining this code is is not the best
but there's many things to take away
from this one is that the tasks wrap or
capture the exceptions or they swallow
the exceptions or whatever you want to
call it you have to validate that the
task completed properly
and the way that we do that is by either
appending a continuation
we would also get a uh an exception if
we asked for the result
if I know
so I'll show you this here if I know
that this task has completed I could
inside the continuation
say runtask.result
if it returned a result
so if the task returns a result I could
ask for the result in here and if that
task has an exception calling this
property will throw it back and you're
only ever allowed to use this property
inside a continuation or after you have
a weighted a task
but we're going to get to the await
keyword in just a moment
so this is the basics of how to use the
TPL and the task parallel Library it's
not very nice to have to always append
these continuations but you can still do
this to intercept when a task is done
so let's jump over to uh to PowerPoint
again and talk about some considerations
so one of the things is that we should
be really careful about wrapping code in
task.1 because as we saw here if I have
some UI interactions or something that
relies on static data just wrapping that
in a task.run might break both my
application and some of the logic which
is not really good
and again I can't reiterate reiterate
this enough thread static data is
unreliable there's another type called
asynclocal that you could use if you
want to use static data but it's a
specific type used to flow across their
synchronous context
and we always want to validate our tasks
so how do we do that we add a continue
with or we introduce the async and Away
keywords which is what we're going to do
next but before we do that I do want to
to mention that there's this extension
to the task parallel Library called a
parallel extensions this method called
parallel 4 is a way for you to
distribute work introduce parallel
programming so in this case here I'm
saying that I want to do some work it's
a from 0 to 100 distribute this across
all my available threads and cores and
whatnot it will ask the.net runtime to
do this evenly so if you're running this
on a two core machine it's going to run
two things at a time on my workstation
it's going to run 32 things at a time
which is really good but this is a
blocking call so as soon as you do
parallel.4 it will block the current
thread so that it can use all the other
available threads to do the work on so
we can combine the asynchronous
principles and parallel programming by
simply wrapping this in a task
the problem with this is that you are
then consuming a thread to just wait for
that work to be done
all right so now that we have a little
bit of an idea of the task parallel
Library we're going to introduce the
async innovate keywords which is purely
a contextual keyword or two contextual
keywords that means that they really
don't have a an impact on the IL that is
generated by the compiler the compiler
is only using Code available also in
older versions of c-sharp it's relying
on some types in.net such as the task
parallel library to be able to context
switch between threads to offload work
to the correct place and to validate
that the tasks are completed
so the async network keyword the the
whole purpose of this is to hide
complexity all of the code that I just
wrote with the continue with appending
another continue with and so forth you
want to get rid of all of that
it's also then a way for us to increase
the readability but you know hiding
complexity making something more
readable means it's more error prone so
if we don't understand exactly what
happens it's gonna get ugly and it's
gonna get us into situations where we
get bugs
so take a look at this example here we
have a very simple method it's marked as
being async it always returns a task so
as soon as you see the async keyword you
should always return a task that is a
way for you to add validation to this
and then I have the await keyword and
these two should always be used together
it doesn't make sense to have the async
keyword without also using a weight
for some reason the compiler allows you
to
there's a reason for that and it's
because how the compiler looks at this
and how it generates code but really it
should have looked at your code and said
hey you're not using that
so basically here I have a variable
declaration I do something
asynchronously
and say that I want to run some work
somewhere and then I don't want to run
the the line at the bottom until we have
a result
the await keyword will do quite a few
things it will in produce one of these
continuations very much like the
continue with method but slightly
different it will also make sure that it
returns back to the original context
it will also validate if there is a
success or failure
so it will check so that there's no
exceptions so if we use async and await
all the way
we won't we won't swallow any exceptions
at least that's the hope
and it also this is a little bit of a
tricky one it also returns to whoever is
calling this method as soon as you have
the await keyword do you see the await
keyword that's going to return to every
caller method so that it can wait for it
we'll take a look at an example of that
so what does this mean for asp.net and
the thread pool that's used in asp.net
if we use async and await all the way
through our asp.net core apis it will be
a lot more performant because what it
does is that even though you have a
request that's waiting for a response
that request is just tied into IIs or
Tiding to the web server so you can
still go ahead and ask other web
services or the disk for some file and
be able to handle more requests at the
time you can release the thread back
onto the thread pool so that asp.net can
go ahead and handle some more things
so by introducing async and await all
the way through our application it's
going to be better at scaling and much
more performance
so then how do we validate a task I
mentioned that we can introduce the
await keyword and we can also use the
the continue with method
all right and we should always use these
together
let's go into Visual Studio again and
I'm going to try and change this
application into using the async and
avoid keywords instead
I don't particularly like this code that
I have at the bottom here for some
obvious reasons so instead instead of
having to add this entire chain of of
checks
I could only say oh wait C for example
this will now validate that there's no
exceptions and if this task returns some
text
I I no longer have to um
I I can get get that as well
so let's change this up a little bit
here too in fact return some text so I
have this this continuation I can still
combine these Concepts together I have a
task that I'm running after that task is
done I might want to manipulate some
data or do something so instead I'm
going to return some data
so now this here turned into a task of a
string
I'm gonna grab this
and what I want to do is that I want to
get the result
out of this operation
so you can even spell result and now
this is going to give me the string so
not only is it going to validate that
the task completed properly that there
was no exceptions it's also going to
give me the result
so then I no longer have to use the
dispatcher
because what's also going to happen here
when it sees the await keyword it's
going to make sure that all the code
after is going to be executing on the
original thread which is quite awesome
so if we look at this code from top to
bottom
there's one more thing we're going to
fix in here but basically we're going to
come into this method we're going to be
on the UI thread
and we can see here that task.run is
going to execute some code elsewhere so
therefore this here that line is going
to be thread X
and then this is also going to be
running somewhere else we could say that
the the continuation is running on
thread y we don't know it could be in
line with red X or thread white it
doesn't really matter but as soon as we
get back here we're going to be back on
the UI thread
and this is the power of whatever's
happening inside this generated State
machine and all the generated code
that's this is doing internally
so there's quite a lot of things going
on here and also things that could go
wrong
all right so I want to show you another
another thing that's really important
normally I said that wrapping wrapping
calls inside a task that run is a bad
idea what's better is to use the
available asynchronous apis
in our case instead of doing
thread.sleep there's a task.delay
if you have a file dot read all lines
there's a file.read alllines async so
you want to refactor your code instead
of just wrapping things in the task.run
refactor the code make sure that you use
the appropriate asynchronous apis
so now with this set here
what we can do is that we are retrieving
the result we are having have some delay
I'm going to put some break points in
here so that you can see the flow of how
this application is going to work
so the first thing that's going to
happen I'm going to run this
I'm going to click the button
it's going to call this this method
it's going to to update my UI it is then
after two seconds it's going to come
back into this application again so let
me run this a little bit slower or
actually increase this to 10 seconds
talk too much that's why it's
there we go after 10 seconds we're going
to come back and it's going to run the
code after this I can move my UI around
I can do some other work and then after
all of those all that delay is done it's
going to come back and run the code
exactly where we took off
which is why the async and Away keywords
are so powerful
now if we happen so we don't have to use
the continue with this is just a way to
show you that you can return data out of
that as well and that would give you a
task of a generic type
so of course I want to show you this as
well that if we now have this
asynchronous method this was also have
to be in async task because I want to
say that when you click the button you
have to validate that the operation that
you are running is also appropriate that
is also didn't have any problems
again we have to add the await keyword
this would then have to be marked as
async
so a little bit of an interesting
approach here would be if we have some
code that updates the UI
let's say that I'm going to say starting
and then at the end we're going to say
that it's completing
you'll notice that if I put a breakpoint
in here and here I'm going to decrease
this to five seconds instead
I'm going to click run
starting I'm going to go into this
method
it's going to release the the the
control back to the UI and then after
five seconds we're going to be back
inside this method and afterwards we're
going to run the code after their weight
inside our run click what's interesting
is if I capture this as a task instead
and update the UI and then add
this equator at the bottom here
what's going to happen I said this
briefly that it's going to return back
to whoever called the method we're going
to go into do something run some code
it's going to take five seconds and then
it's going to immediately return back to
this click event Taylor to run some code
so you can run this code as long as
there's no await keyword it's just going
to continue the execution
all right and then
I want to show you this as well what
happens if we actually throw an
exception
if we throw an exception
actually I'm going to do down here
instead if we're inside the continuation
and the continuation throws an exception
we're going to be able to capture that
here
so do this
try
I'm going to catch the exception let's
do some Pokemon programming catch them
all
I keep it a break point in here of
course
I didn't like that obviously didn't like
that
there we go
so now that my continuation throws an
exception
we'll be able to capture that so after
the two seconds are up it's going to
continue with something that throws an
exception which I'm awaiting so
hopefully I'll be able to capture that
exception and get that inside this this
tri-cat block now I'm rethrowing this
back to ever calls this method and as
long as they are also
as long as they are also awaiting this
we would capture this exception but what
happens
if we are simply looking at this method
saying hey I I don't care about awaiting
this sometimes I see developers doing
something like this
I just want to call this method and I'm
going to discard the task that we are
executing the problem here is that if I
run this without the debugger attached
and click run
after five seconds
let's see what happens nothing happens
because I forgot to await this so I did
a fire and forget
I got an exception inside the task
without the await keyword
I haven't validated that it's executed
properly
so it's really important that we always
do async and awaits together and that we
await them properly because this was
marked as being an async task it would
capture this exception and put it
internally in that task
so what are really the implications of
adding the async keyword there's a lot
that happens to be able to control this
to find the the thread you're going back
to to jump between these different
contexts
this here introduces a state machine and
a state machine is simply like a child
in the back seat of the car asking you
if you're there yet
can be quite annoying
but it works
doesn't really work like this it's not a
wild true Loop that keeps nagging you if
you're done
what it's done doing is much more clever
so if it figures out that your work is
not done it's going to schedule its own
code to execute when that operation is
done
so it's doing a lot of heavy lifting
internally and the stake machine is what
handles the potential results or
potential errors and make sure that
they're set on the correct place or
communicate it back to whoever's using
the asynchronous apis
it also executes all the code after the
await keyword
so the async keyword just to reiterate
it generates a state machine but it also
what you'll notice soon is that it moves
all of your code inside your method body
into somewhere else
now that doesn't necessarily sound like
a bad idea but if you don't understand
exactly what's happening sometimes when
you look at a stack Trace especially in
older versions of c-sharpon.net it can
be quite confusing to understand exactly
what's happening
again if we have this very simple method
that's not doing a lot it just marks
async task it's declaring a variable it
has a task at delay which is just
representing in a synchronous operation
and then does something afterwards when
we compile this
the code is no longer going to look
anything like what we had earlier this
has now replaced all of the code inside
our method moved it into a generated
class
and this isn't always going to be a
problem but as you'll see here at the
bottom this is what Returns the task now
if if I just go back here you'll see
that this is marked async task when I
compile it there's no longer an async
keyword because the IL or or CLI doesn't
know anything about the async keyword it
knows about tasks but it doesn't know
anything about the async keyword
but what it will do and that's why you
don't have to return a task manually the
state machine will have a task that
represents the work that's going on and
if there's a result available if there's
any exceptions cancellations and so
forth so that's what what is returning
automatically here
if we drill into the state machine
that's compiled we can see that there's
a little bit of code that we might
recognize this is just inside a little
bit of the state machine we're not going
to spend too much time looking at this
here I love looking in the state machine
but that's just me because I'm a little
bit weird but
we have the variable declaration
we have the task delay which could be
our asynchronous operation
it's getting the a waiter for this to
check if it's completed or not if it's
not completed it's going to return out
of this state machine in this check and
then the outer thing that executed the
state machine will schedule this work on
the tasks continuation
so it's using the task parallel library
and doing some very clever things
internally
and then
all of this code here inside the state
machine is being executed on your UI
thread or the main thread or the calling
thread depends on where you call this
from that is why the final portion of
this code will be then executed on the
UI thread
which is quite amazing so with that
being said I've all I've said now that
we have to use async task but what
happens if we use async void
I would be much more sad than than just
dropping an ice cream so is it really
that bad obviously otherwise I wouldn't
have brought it up
the question is what happens internally
if we Mark something as async void
this is here the only difference here
between the other code sample is that I
don't have task as a return type I
change it to void My Method doesn't have
to do anything other than just changing
the return type to task or void but if I
look at the decompiled code
there's no way for me to track the
internal State of the State machine this
is no longer returning anything from
this generated code and that's
problematic because how would I know if
there's an exception how would I know if
it completed
how would I know if there's something
that didn't work as situative
I say this sometimes like if I ever see
a car written in C sharp that's using
async void
I'm not driving that
so how do we fix this
it's quite simple and subtle we change
void to task and everything should just
work
question is will it
let's jump over to visual studio again
and this here I know that if we await
this it's gonna throw an exception
because if we are wrapping this in a try
catch
like this here
if I wrap it on try catch I know that
it's going to catch an exception because
we threw one earlier
I can then set a breakpoint in here
if I run this with a debugger attached
I'm going to remove some of the
breakpoints because they're a little bit
unnecessary for now
am I still running the application
doesn't like that
here we go
click run
and after a little while
I think there's still going to be an
exception here we go
can capture this it's going to rethrow
it and whoever's awaiting that call is
now
capable of capturing this which is great
but the problem is what happens if I
cannot await this I know that do
something is in reality do something
async
but um
if it's async void the consumer of this
method has no idea that this is running
something else
we're running semi-synchronous code
except for the naming Convention of the
method
so what happens now
I'm going to try catch this like it's
similar to before
I'm going to run the application without
the debugger attached I know that this
is still going to throw an exception I'm
going to try and move this around and
after five seconds
the application crashes
so for some reason
I was not able to capture this exception
the problem here is that if we just look
at the code from top to bottom and think
about what's going on here
I'm going to run do something
this here is an asynchronous method
right it has an await keyword somewhere
in here here we go Gotta Wait here that
means it's going to return back to
whoever is calling this method right
which would be the next line in our
click event handler
so we've already exited the try catch
block when that asynchronous operation
is done which means I don't I haven't
wrapped anything in a try catch block
because that asynchronous operation is
running somewhere else
so I guess the the designers of this
language feature figured that well if
you cannot add a try catch block around
this method because because of the
internal implementations
the best thing that we can do is just
kill the application
don't know if I agree it would have been
nice to have any way from recovering
from this but there's not
and I guess the the best approach here
would have been to not mark this as
async void
because there's more problems with async
void
I have no way of tracking the work I
have no way of ensuring that it
completed successfully I can't capture
any exceptions
but with that being said it's quite
confusing that my click event handler
has to be async void
this is because delegates that require
it such as click event handlers you
can't really change this to async task
because then it doesn't correspond with
the delegate so they have to also
support async void but it's solely
purpose is for event handlers
and all of this is similar in other
types of applications as well not just
WPF
so what's the fix to this how do we make
sure that our applications don't just
crash when we have async void it's a
very simple fix
don't write code that cause exceptions
easier said than done right
all right so
another problem when we come when we
talk about asynchronous programming is
often that we we reach places where we
cannot recover from such as deadlocks a
deadlock is a pretty bad experience it
means that the application is no longer
responding a lot of cases the operating
system doesn't even know that it's not
responding anymore so you can't even
kill the application without going into
the task manager
a little bit problematic I have an
example here that looks complex but if
we if we pull it apart and talk about
the different pieces here it's really
not that very complex I have some code
that runs asynchronously inside the
continuation of that I want to
communicate with the UI
but I'm going to block the UI call wait
or call Dot result
this here will cause a Deadlock
now this looks very complex but I
promise you that this happens very often
and this is also a problem as I
mentioned earlier most of this is also
affected in in WPF winforms asp.net so
no matter which type of framework you're
using or type of application you can
reach a Deadlock
which is not very good because if you
keep deadlocking in asp.net eventually
you're going to run out of threads to
respond to your resources or your
requests
and then what many people do as I see it
they just scale up their application and
just get more and more and more
expensive
it's better to not block now this here
looks complex as I've said a few times
now A more interesting way of do
performing a deadlock is to apply dot
weight to an asynchronous operation
so let's uh let's do this let's have a
look at how to to perform this really
bad experience I'm going to clear out
this this method a little bit it's
getting a little bit noisy
so instead
what I'm going to do here this is called
this is now marked as async task I want
to do await task.delay and I want to dla
for two seconds after which I want to do
debug dot text which is something in my
UI
now if I call this method
and block the operation or block
whatever this is doing
actually I'm going to copy this as well
here we go if I call do something
do something
and then I wanted to wait I want to
force this to wait
because I don't want to bother making my
entire application asynchronous
the problem here is that when I create
do something this generates a state
machine the state machine runs on the UI
that means that surely enough the first
line is going to execute then it's going
to run on asynchronous operation it
could be an HTTP call right we all know
that by now
when that is done
the rest of the state machine needs to
execute on the UI thread it needs to
come back to the original thread but how
can this line execute if we are blocking
the UI from more execution
therefore we have a Deadlock
if we really want to to introduce
blocking code I've got you there's a way
to do this as well
or we can do
is that we can we can wrap the call
to do something
in a new task and block the UI
so why will this work
there's going to be more bugs in here
but we're going to fix that for now this
here will solve one problem it allows me
to block this to introduce synchronous
code
don't repeat that I said that this is a
good idea
so what actually happens now is that we
move the state machine of do something
to a different thread I'm going to block
the UI but since the thread that owns
the state machine is not blocked
it can say that it's done and the weight
operation will then also know that the
state machine is done and then we can
come back and execute whatever's next
a better approach is of course
to do a weight to do something
much better
so I guess the most important part here
is to never block anything the same goes
for DOT result
don't do that
So to avoid Deadlocks what we want to do
is that we want to avoid result weight
we do not want to confuse using weight
all with weight any or when when all
because this is also the same thing as
blocking which is problematic
a little bit more of an advanced
scenario we don't want to share locks
basically or have nested locks because
that's also a very easy way to get a
Deadlock
now there's one thing that I do also
want to say here that we can avoid
introducing unnecessary amounts of State
machines because this is code that's
executing somewhere and it's a little
bit unnecessary to introduce code if we
don't need to there's complexity that we
don't need
some others might say different but look
at this code snippet here for example I
have a method called run async this is
calling run internal async and again
naming methods is not my best thing
that's not what I do
it's simply a chain of asynchronous
operations
the problem here is that there's nothing
happening inside the continuations of
these different methods
and I'd like to say that if there's
nothing inside the continuation you
might not actually have to await that
I know that someone has probably read
David Fowler's best practices of
asynchronous programming where it says
that you should always await everything
which is true because it's it's the best
way to always ensure that you don't run
into any problems
but for more advanced scenarios and
where you want to have really high
performance it might be a bad idea to
always introduce async and await if you
don't need to
but then someone is also going to say
I've heard that you need to do async all
the way but that doesn't mean that we
can't avoid introducing unnecessary
async methods
I see people always appending the async
keyword when there's a task return from
a method you don't have to just because
you see the task you don't have to make
it async
but you should always await everything
at the top level
so what does that actually mean let's
have a look at some of the code that
I've written here
I've already prepared a little bit of a
solution that's going to let us
to experiment with this so
this here is a very simple application
main method which can be async now you
start a new program run async call some
internal thing has a con continue with
to it
and it's just a normal simple chain of
asynchronous operations
now the the final portion here is
actually starting two-way sequence
operations and I can improve this since
they are both independent of each other
like ideally I could say that I want to
await task dot when all instead
which lets me now start these operations
at the same time
so that's a little bit of a performance
Improvement if it's okay to do that
sometimes you want to have to awaits
that's totally fine as well
but honestly if I'm not doing anything
inside my continuation down here and
this here doesn't require me to come
back to a certain thread it doesn't
require me to not be disposed
if I remove the async keyword and simply
return this
the contract or the method signature is
going to be the same
so as soon as you create a task that run
for example if you do that in WPF or win
forms or console apps you don't always
have to await it in the same method
that is only true for things like HTTP
client or database operations
there is also a little gotcha here this
might mess up your stack Trace
but honestly the stack Trace with async
and await is already a little bit messed
up
so it might actually not make a huge
difference it depends so I could go
ahead and refactor my entire application
to remove async and awaits
and to return this
I could even do that up here where I'm
appending a continuation so what this is
doing is that I'm running my internal
method which I'm then appending a
continuation to that means that the
tasks that are returned from this method
is going to be the last task added to
this chain
it's going to be only executing then
once all of the tasks are completed so
this is a small Improvement to the
generated code but it's only good in the
scenarios where you can really trust
that you don't need
um things like the HTTP client for
example
or rely on the stack Trace
all right
let's go ahead and talk about the next
big thing which is cancellations now I
just want to briefly mention this
because I get this question quite often
what happens if I introduce a
cancellation token
this is what you use to cancel an
ongoing operation I can start an ongoing
operation and passing a cancellation
token and this should be disposed
properly and you so you don't have any
memory leaks different topic
now what happens if we are then calling
this long running operation as you'll
see here I'm calling this long-running
operation and to the task that's
executing this I'm passing in the
cancellation token
this the implementation of this method
has a wild true Loop
doesn't do anything fancy
what happens if I try to cancel my
ongoing operation
will it cancel this method how would it
know where to cancel it
actually if you call cancellation token
dot cancel nothing is actually going to
happen
because how would it know where in the
code to stop
you would have to monitor for that
yourself by introducing for example in
this case I'm throwing an exception
to say that I want to throw if a
cancellation has been requested
this is Handy and it's useful in many
different types of situations where you
might want to cancel an ongoing
operation in asp.net core you can you
can subscribe to the cancellation token
of the request so you could say that if
they request terminates determined all
the the requests that are you've
currently started because of that
request which is quite handy and when it
comes to asynchronous database
operations I just want to leave you here
with a warning to say that if core
doesn't support multiple parallel
operations on the same context that's
why you couldn't just return the task
for example from save save async or save
changes async you have to always await
that to make sure that it works properly
so in some situations you can return a
task and in some situations you have to
await it
there's also also another interesting
concept that is quite new and that's
streaming data asynchronous streams was
introduced in in c-sharp 8 and allows
you to define something called an iasync
enumerable
let's say that I want to stream all this
data I am indicating that I'm going to
stream strings it could be messages that
I have on an Azure message queue it
could be anything this here is the
producer side of things so what I do
here is that I'm going to say that this
method produces streams of a stream of
of strings I don't know how many it
could be in infinite
to consume this I could say that I want
to await for each element that I can get
out of this
so I have a sample of this as well so we
can go and break this down and look at
this in Visual Studio
so I have a again a Windows application
fairly similar to what we've just looked
at
it has this method called get lyrics it
Returns on iasink enumerable of a string
this just indicates that this will
produce strings on the Fly
I'm using a using declaration to open a
stream to a file on disk
I have a while loop that will say that
I'm going to read a line from the disk
and then I'm going to use pattern
matching to say that I want to ensure
that this has been set to an instance of
a string if I say VAR here it would also
capture nulls which is a little bit
problematic because then I'm never going
to to exit this while loop so it has to
be an instance of a string not null
and then I can simply do a weight
task.delay again just to simulate that
I'm processing some data here this could
have been a message from from Azure who
knows
to tell this innumerable or the iterator
that's iterating through my elements
that there's a some data available I can
now use yield Return To indicate to
whoever is listening that there's now a
new string available
I'm going to put some break points in
here
and then we're going to consume this
method I have a a run async method here
it's marked as async because we have the
await keyword
and normally before we look at the
implementation normally what you see is
that you have the await in front of the
method call that would have indicated
that I want this entire chunk of data
in this case
I want to say that I'm going to retrieve
each line inside this stream of data I
don't know how many
which is why you couldn't say to array
for example
because what would that have indicated
give me everything if it's indefinite
let's run out of memory not a good idea
so instead
I'm going to process each element as I
want and for example if I want to break
out of this I could do that as well as
you'll see here I can actually cancel
this operation and say that if you've
pressed cancel in the application I'm
going to throw an exception I could also
say that if token dot is
what was it CTS if
let's go back
if cts.token dot is cancellation
requested break I could do that as well
if I wanted to
but I like to throw exceptions so let's
do that
throw wave cancellation is requested now
if I put a breakpoint here
and press and start the application with
the debugger
I'm going to click run and this will
then try to iterate through this this
stream of data so I could then go ahead
and read each line it's easier way it's
going to return to the UI yield return
will be able to then use this inside my
for each Loop then it's going to go
ahead and read the next line
which is quite nice
I will also show you this that since
this is an iasync enumerable
what if we are simply calling the method
without iterating through it what would
that entail I can take this and say
VAR enumerable
and if I don't do this
what is that going to happen
is it going to read anything from my
file
press F5
didn't do anything
so just by calling the method it won't
even
start start up the stream to the file on
disk it won't even start reading
anything
so you have to
then iterate through this
and the good thing is that I don't have
to do the method called inline with my
for each loop I could say for each line
in the innumerable like you can with any
eye normable or any array of data
so I'm going to run this again without
the debugger
hopefully that's going to work
or Visual Studio crashes
whichever
whatever it wants
come on
I don't think it liked me doing this
so
let's see here
now run this
and here we go
perfect it's now streaming data into my
WPF application it's using all of those
principles of the task parallel Library
switching back and forth to the UI each
time it reads this text and processes
that on the other thread like it's going
to relieve the the control back to the
UI which is very powerful so without
understanding all of the internals of
the async and avoid keywords the task
parallel library and how all of this
works together this could have been very
confusing maybe it's still but you know
you have my email
it is a complex topic
and I also want to to leave you on the
note of saying that there's this thing
called a configure await
some sometime back in the day everyone
was told to always append configure away
it falls to all your asynchronous
operations
because that's the best practice and it
used to be like that because in asp.net
previously not in asp.net core it tried
to always come back to the original
thread to do everything inside the
continuation I've mentioned this right
so when we inside our application
if we are doing um
like a way to task a delay for example
it's going to come back to the UI thread
here at the bottom which is exactly what
we want to but if I say configure await
false
this is now going to execute this on
thread y or thread X or whatever it's
going to execute this continuation
somewhere else and in asp.net that meant
that it was very much more performant
because you didn't have to ask for the
original thread on the thread pool that
originally worked on your response
now the problem of course is that if you
relied on HTTP context it wouldn't be
available down here so you might have
the HTTP context here at the top but
then at the bottom here that would be
null because it's not available on
another thread
a little bit problematic but they've
fixed this so in newer versions of
asp.net in asp.net core
there's no longer a concept of a
synchronization context so it doesn't
have to come back to anywhere so by
default it will always just execute
whatever code is after a weight on the
current thread and it just works
everything just flows across the new
HTTP context flows across properly all
the data that you would expect to be
available is available in your
asynchronous context
so there's quite a lot happening with
both the async and 08 keywords and I
have like five to ten hours of content
on pluralsight on all of this where you
can dig into a lot more in depth and
more samples and learn more about this
because honestly an hour is is just
enough to understand a little bit about
the problems that we can have with the
async and Away keywords in the task
parallel Library there's quite a lot
happening behind the hoods and it's good
to get a little bit of an inspiration as
to where to go next so check out my
courses and I hope you've enjoyed this
and do send me an email if you have any
problems in your work or any issues with
async in a weight or c-sharp feel free
to send me an email and don't forget to
leave a card on the way out thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]
thank you